with his recent win in rev major
jonding is no doubt one of the most
exciting players in the tekken community
with his amazing gameplay and fun
personality he always gets the crowd
going no matter where he goes
john
[Laughter]
he killed me with the look there he is
not happy oh my god
pronounce my name correctly it's not
jung
here are the top 10 moments of jonding
in tekken tournaments
[Applause]
[Music]
that's scary man that was impressive
that was the presence considering how
badly poked up beat bab earlier
oh my god john didn't know
john
digg no
john gang
i think he's turned the crowd i think
he's done it
oh let's go
grab his own crazy for both now
beautiful
oh boy we got a mess boy oh wait he
might have dropped that he robbed him
he'd been looking at him he was looking
at him while he dropped the combo
oh my god that's why you don't do that
that's why you don't do that
oh hob kicked this ticket is he gonna
look at him again he's gonna look at the
screen
oh my god he dropped the ender again
he was looking at the screen that time
oh
no
and it's gonna be two rounds straight
for john thinks that both of them should
have been [ __ ] up
wow
wow
this is a bad situation to be in right
now range mode pokestop is a good thing
oh not like that it's not
and john ding
gonna eliminate pokemon
[Music]
that low swipe such a good tool here
especially in this matchup in particular
the gravest drive is gonna hit redundant
can he close it out here he might be
able to get it yes he does game one for
john day oh your wish might
he's got to watch out back the wall here
wiggling his way out of there yeah nice
able to stake out away oh my gosh here
we go oh my gosh
we're gonna have to be careful yeah time
winding down here johnny with the
tiniest of leads with eight seconds ago
oh he's got a bigger lead time left and
no rage for chance i can't make a rage
come back oh he's not raised now can he
do anything two seconds johnny's just
gonna hold back and that'll do it john
ding impressive stuff three to two
eliminates jdc are in the loser final
yeah something
[Music]
here comes the rage he might go for the
throw down and he could hit you running
three for the pressure do you went for
the throw again oh he stops the rage out
of normal rage for john ding
dancing
great patience of course but man he had
an opportunity to close down earlier
look at he's he is like he just stood up
what was
[Music]
it's going either way who's gonna take
this oh my god the evasive punch back
one plus two able to get out the
superman punch
and right now he's in a little bit of
trouble but life are still very close
johnny might be able to close out game
two right here
has a chance gets the follow-up here
puts him into rage the drive's coming
here comes the 50-50 fly mix-up goes
with the low now he has his own stuff
over the back twelve oh he called it 12.
good good goal that's a win for the
crowd so he gives oh look look at that
playing it up
hilarious
and he's gonna get the wall and the
extra damage here i like what i'm seeing
here looking to close it out put some
it's a range yeah chanel stand on the
ground to take that extra hit of the
stain to raise and stuff's around oh
this could be close this might be a
chance
giggle gets the low this might be it
to throw get off of me
14 seconds chanelle got one more bar
spends it on the fireball
oh god be careful oh i got rid of 50 50.
the mid what's gonna happen i don't know
going to the winner final
[Applause]
wow what an amazing match
[Music]
no way
[Music]
oh get done
oh my god
oh i almost missed down but there we go
huge early lead now 2-0 for low high no
more range available for low highly and
now here's right back gotcha john ding
on the board all right two to one
joining staying alive
he ain't gonna do it again oh
there's a follow-up
and he gets the wall as well look at
this damage
50 50 time this time for the mid nice
dog there it is
here comes the range drive 50 50 time
wait for the mid it's like putting the
brakes on it oh
opportunity johnny still can close it
out but i try to stay in this game don't
miss the range right never mind
we're all tied up that was out straight
down
oh boy what's he gonna do oh did he hit
a button i think he might have not ever
buy oh never find
john ding with them good for john dick
but look out here comes the race now
from jack
50 50 the blow this time
bottom evasive attack goes into the
slide who wants it more he got the
upboard for him
getting the brush look at this life lead
right now it's looking really good for
judging we got this leopard that should
be it john dick trying to close it out
here john
[Music]
[Applause]
a rematch of what we saw in our winners
finals
[Music]
oh oh oh he flashed in between he knows
that there is a gap in between that
attack three four yep
again spin to rage oh downpour two ducks
underneath the high
oh the power crunch wow that was
beautiful
there from my musician now continue the
pressure he does have a slight life lead
here but down to the ring what's gonna
happen
whole second
natural combo ten seconds now this is
where the healing is gonna become a huge
factor timewise
so much to play for
again he caught him he's gonna have to
adjust the combo let's see he goes for
the back two four this time what's the
mix up gets up with the low yeah i like
to relax there for the oaky
big league oh they traded blows look at
this a huge like lead but he has great
so you cannot count him out chunks oh
[Music]
what an adjustment there on the fly from
judding moving on down
[Music]
nice right in this oh just the tip
here's the bound
all right now what are you going to do
oh that's it
jonah takes it and finally dethrones
drops the combo
a little too far out there
oh that should be it
yeah
[Music]
oh that was amazing what a bait
[Applause]
now newton coming back strong now
winning three street matches for his
team
oh
god
[Music]
no time left
what's gonna happen he's gonna have to
do something oh
he went for a
a
step right there
oh
rodeo beat it out
nice okay
[Music]
he's oh crazy
[Music]
oh there's the rage drive
what's mixed up
oh wow okay heads up
oh
oh
he's on reach he's on reach
it's not over yet
slide he slides
in away what's gonna happen
oh oh
oh
my god
the
jaunting oh wow nice punish
dojin in rage though what's going to
happen
oh what's up the first throw of the top
eight i've seen so far oh but not over
yet
oh
but dungeon eating
oh the rage drive
isn't going to kill
oh my god
john thanks for the doji oh
god
doshin with these decisions
what is happening john ding down
another one
one more setup
jumping what the heck one hit away
what is happening people
my heart oh no
oh
oh my god
john ding
finishing the one two for the two
oh my god what was that that was intense
[Music]
all right here we go
oh not in the rear jimmy james got the
red stuff he decides
though yeah but the question is you've
got a korean player sitting right in
front of you and he's alive
oh yeah
he's baited he's aware of every mix-up
counter hit you gotta get it kind of
hurt and carrie yeah you better go
oh man he gets up the mix up
oh power across flat
this might be oh my god
trying to go over that three four
[Music]
[Music]
two man jimmy is so composed look at all
these the blurry is coming at him
how long are you gonna block all this oh
get the counter hit and it's gonna hurt
like him
oh my god
[Music]
oh
[Applause]
listen to the crowd here oh
get up
oh geez everybody shut the [ __ ] up
oh my god
oh my gosh
oh my god it's anything's gonna do it
why write the three four race draft
oh oh my god and not dean
jimmy
oh my god
what a stick
[Music]
messing up oh my gosh
so like he marches his way to the center
but the slippery kick once again mark
ben huge stuff he's got to close this
one out one more hit would do it goes
for the low john king not making
decisions here the gin play looks like
on paper it's been working out but right
now jumping is turning things around
side step
the wall situation is on his side a deep
butt is bleeding red goes for the low
john things in the lead ladies and
gentlemen you're gonna go to akuma
that's what a lot of people have to
think about is he going to switch
characters and johnny looking very
intensely what's happening no he's got
to get back up
janelle's in here chanel to god both of
them
giving each other words of wisdom
calling on an angel calling on a friend
hopefully that's poking away chipping
away oh
he finished it
now more pressure against the wall gets
the balcony this is gonna be big because
not only is he gonna get damaged he's
gonna have the opportunity to do and do
more mix-ups through now we see chanting
with a sizeable lifeleader but only has
rage on his side chances on him oh and
the second he led the insurance
able to get it and now john digs outside
of race but no speck of hell can you
make this come at half and no one will
it be
johnny gonna two foot shocking for that
positioning the down four two series
again pushing to the wall sidewall stun
oh man he's dancing on him he's counting
but the teeth but able to get the big
low sean thing in trouble here
face boards able to get a sizable combo
but a team but still is in that deficit
area oh this is big he gets the throw
that's gonna be guaranteed
one more would do it for dante the rage
drive gets denied splash 30 seconds oh
my god this is huge he's not going to be
able to kill him though he's not going
to be able to do it no
he has rage oh another low able to go
for the ranger nothing goes wild they
rush the stage oh my goodness ladies and
gentlemen pandemonium and the red major
stage
[Music]
he's still got the raging it's just a
pixel oh he's just out of range he gets
it
but is it going to be oh
god the lone pair
he has another opportunity
to kill either mix up
the return
[Music]
very tight right now looking for the
reason
john ding resetting the grand finals
three oh wait a second it actually
interrupted oh he's in trouble now
johnny can pick open got the razor get
stopped that's sucked for him oh yeah
that just like that he doesn't even do
extra damage anymore
oh
that's gonna be enough damage is it
though it's a final round that is
definitely a though tournament point for
john ding
one round away oh he's got the slippery
kick get his big he's gonna do a lot of
damage back to both ways in the back
wall standing two on the back kudos to
converting with the electric into the
wall here comes the wall combo five
another one oh getting it out of them
kudos closes it out of ties and up
johnny was that one round
available he did go for it oh he got
floated anyway
oh is it okay he hits the range this
time all right kudos pulling it back
yeah that was scary for a moment could
have had the round early but he closed
it out the rage art anyway first round
final game
kick what's he gonna do with one hit
away oh john dig again
oh it's a follow-up what's he going to
do
doesn't reset grand finals john ding
trying to win the tournament can he do
it here big block big punish godot isn't
gonna happen
we're going to a final final round
like the hell we missed they're finally
coming out oh my god he's gonna step up
the wall too mixed up what's he gonna do
demon paw johnny way behind he's got the
ring he's got to make a rage come back
down oh the right guy
the wall's right there the wall's right
there what's he gonna do fifty-fifty you
gotta blow it up
johnny wins the tournament john king
with ceo 2018 here in daytona the crowd
is going wow i don't think i've ever
seen a spring kick win it like that
[Applause]
so do you think he is the best eddie and
lucky chloe player just leave your
comments below and make sure to
subscribe too once again i'm drew and
thanks for watching ochoto tv
bye
you